- It's funny because the
simulation hypothesis,
for the listeners that may not know,
is basically the supposition
that as computing power doubles
every year, year and a half,
according to what's known as Moore's law,
your computers get cheaper,
they get more powerful,
they get faster, and
that that extrapolation,
there's no natural starting point,
I mean, when you made the
first computer or whatever,
that for us is.
But could it not be that
they get to so much power
that they can simulate
every single physical object
in the universe, and if
we're just material objects,
our brains are just wet computers,
but they're just computers,
they have neurons, they have
carbon, and DNA, and so forth,
but why couldn't that be simulated
in some great, vast
supercomputer of the future
that doesn't exist yet?
But we would be kind of like
the "SimCity" or whatever.
- We'd be in "The Matrix," in essence.
- Yeah, we'd be in "The Matrix."
(gentle solemn music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today
is a distinguished professor of physics
at the Center for Astrophysics
and Space Sciences
at UC San Diego, and
author of the new book,
"Into the Impossible: Think
Like a Nobel Prize Winner."
Brian Keating, finally,
welcome to "The Rubin Report."
- Thank you, Dave.
You were my first big guest on my podcast,
so it's nice to return the favor.
I know you've been looking forward
to having a big guest
like me on for a while.
(both laughing)
- I've wanted a man of science
on for quite some time.
No, I've wanted to talk to
you for a while on this show,
because I think this will
be a little bit different
than the shows that we normally do.
But framing one thing sort of politically,
just to jump us off,
as a man of science and as
a man that just wrote a book
about how scientists approach science,
what do you make of the state
of science at the moment?
Science is getting pretty
banged up these days.
- Yeah, it's tough.
I used to say I enjoy being an astronomer
because there's no Republican asteroids,
there's no Democratic
comets, it's apolitical.
But it's become incredibly
politicized, as you point out.
I always point out, Dave,
the word science in Latin,
I know you're a scholar
so you'll know this,
the word science means knowledge.
It doesn't mean wisdom.
So to expect wisdom from people
that are knowledge junkies...
Wikipedia has a lot of knowledge.
It doesn't have any wisdom.
You wouldn't want to trust
your dog with it, right?
So I do believe that we're living
in a fundamentally
scientific technological age
that kind of is worshiping scientists
way more than I think we warrant.
As anyone who's ever known the
famous joke about scientists,
how do you know a scientist is outgoing?
Because he looks at your
shoes when he talks to you.
(both laughing)
And it's part of the goal of this book
is to humanize scientists
and to recognize that
we're just human beings.
We have no special truth claims
or wisdom claims than anyone else.
- Does that chasm between
knowledge and wisdom
sorta capture exactly the
moment we're at in a way?
Where it's like, we hear
things every day in the news.
Okay, there's a new study
that says something.
That tells us something about
knowledge to some degree.
But then the wisdom of the policies
that then we are told we have to follow
often seems a little screwy,
at least in my humble opinion.
- Yeah, looking again, if you
look to somebody for wisdom,
again looking to Wikipedia for wisdom
is not gonna be too fruitful.
And yet we crave it,
because we worship at
the altar of science,
in some way justifiably so.
It's led to life increases,
child mortality rates plummeting,
vaccines, and so forth
that are just miraculous
and any other way would be
difficult to describe it,
understanding the composition
evolution of the universe
to a fraction of a
percent, just astonishing.
And yet we don't as
laity, as a lay person,
don't really have a good
understanding of how science works.
So as the words of Arthur C. Clarke said,
"Any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic,"
and some say it could be an
indistinguishable from a God.
And so I think there is a tendency,
a desire to worship at
the altar of science,
and I think that's misplaced.
Because we don't elect
scientists as a population.
We elect politicians, a
president, governors, et cetera.
We elect those people
and they wanna pass off
I think some of their
responsibility to the scientists
who we don't elect
and we wouldn't elect
in any other capacity.
- So last part on this specifically,
but do you sense that
sort of the reputation
that science and scientists
have gotten over the last year
where it's been so
battered and inconsistent,
and wear a mask, don't wear a mask,
the vax is working, it's not working,
booster shots, the whole thing,
do you think it can recover
in the next couple of years?
Because right now, when they
just trot out the next study,
like at this point, I'm just like,
this is just more nonsense.
I'm not saying I don't believe
that the study was conducted,
but what it will always
lead to is just like,
I can't listen to this stuff anymore.
- Well, the biggest misconception
is that science is ever settled.
I think the public has
that to their dismay
because believing that science is settled
is antithetical to science.
Think about it, Dave.
If Galileo came along and said,
"Well, Aristotle was a scientist.
He's very smart.
I'll just accept that there
are only four elements
instead of 114,
or that heavy things fall
faster than light things."
All these things, he could
have verified by the way,
but he didn't actually go out and do that.
But Galileo would never have come up
with the initial Laws of Relativity,
same with Newton, Einstein, because,
"Well, Newton is a genius,
I can outdo Newton,"
as he often looked up to him.
So therefore, as Richard Feynman,
the great Nobel laureate
of the 20th century said,
"Science is the belief in
the ignorance of experts."
Otherwise, you'd have no motivation
to ever modify, refine, and improve upon
who or what came before you.
So I view that and I
view it to the detriment
of science and scientists themselves.
Often people say, "Oh, I'm no Einstein,
I can't understand it."
Well, guess what, Dave?
Einstein wasn't Einstein in
the beginning of his life.
So, I think the more
that we kind of venerate
without explaining how
science is actually done,
it harms our own practitioners
of the craft of science
that I am engaged in.
- Yeah, and that really actually
is what the book is about
because you talk about
things like creativity
and human expression and passion,
all of these things that
we don't really associate
with scientists and
their work specifically.
So, let's just dive in.
So you have nine chapters here,
each one going off a different scientist
for a different reason.
I thought we could just
spend a couple of minutes
on everybody, but you gotta
leave some secrets here,
otherwise people won't buy the book.
So a couple of minutes on
everybody, I know how it works.
Chapter one is about Adam
Riess, the Star Gazer.
- Yeah, so Adam is a contemporary of mine.
He's basically my age, and
back in I think it was 2005,
there was a worldwide competition
to determine who is the greatest scientist
under the age of 40.
And he and I entered it.
I came in first as the most
promising scientist of all time,
at least of that age, and
then Adam came in third.
And so later, six years later
when he won the Nobel Prize,
my older brother, Kevin,
who watches this show,
he called to report on me and said,
"Brian, you won the battle,
but Adam won the war, brother.
(both laughing)
You had the temporary reprieve."
So Adam is an incredibly
curious individual.
He's very young, and what is often said
about the Nobel prize,
in fact, by Nobel laureate, T.S. Eliot,
who won it for literature,
he said, "The Nobel is a
ticket to your own funeral
because no one ever does
it after he wins it."
And Adam has a real
counterexample to that canard
because he has gone on to great heights,
astronomically and otherwise,
educational mentorship, et cetera.
I think he best exemplifies the fact that,
Dave, I never thought I could
be a professional astronomer.
Growing up as we did on
Long Island, I thought like,
"Oh, someone's gonna pay
me to be an astronomer
like they're gonna pay me
to be an ice cream taster
or a wizard or something like that."
So, I really do look at him
as the fulfillment of this
dream that you can do it.
You can achieve your passion.
But passion alone is not enough.
You need to have insatiable curiosity.
I say passion is a spark,
but the fuel is actually curiosity.
- I have to tell you that
growing up on Long Island,
as you noted, in 1997,
I think I told you this
when I was on your podcast,
I ate some pot brownies
and then went to see the movie "Contact"
by the great science communicator,
Carl Sagan.
- Carl Sagan.
- And I was basically tripping,
and I'm sure you've seen
the beginning of that movie many times,
that spectacular panorama of the universe.
And it blew my mind,
and I ended up reading,
I think I've read every one
of Carl Sagan's books since then.
- Wow.
- He had passed away I think a few months
before the movie came out,
but I had read all of his books.
So it is possible that
someone from Long Island
could stare into the
stars and think something.
- Yeah, I had his wife,
his widow, Ann Druyan,
who is a co-author on "Contact,"
and his daughter on my
podcast, Sasha Sagan,
and he had something very
pertinent to your book.
You know, "Don't Burn This Book."
He said, "Books," Dave, "are magic."
They are the implantation of
an author, long dead perhaps,
although not for you or me
hopefully for many centuries to come,
and the wisdom distilled, per word,
the price per word of wisdom in a book.
Carl, you, hopefully me, these
are really invaluable things,
and I think of these as hacks.
And these scholars that
I profile in the book,
they all make use of that
and credit these great
scientists and authors
that came before.
- Let me ask you one other thing
about the people that
look into the distance
that are always trying to figure out
what's going on in the cosmos
and the stars and everything else,
you'll hear now, "Oh, but we
have so many problems here.
We shouldn't be funding
any of these things."
And we know that a lot of it now,
a lot of the exploration
is being done privately,
obviously Elon Musk and some other people.
What do you make of that general outlook?
- Well, I think that the
separating out the space program
and exploration of space
from pure research,
so what I do is called
in one of the chapters
by Nobel laureate, Sheldon Glashow,
what I do, the origin evolution
of the universe, cosmology,
not to be confused with cosmetology,
that you can tell I'm a
master practitioner thereof,
that we do, in his words,
useless ideas. (chuckling)
We basically pursue stuff
that has no net benefit,
at least so we think now,
and here's a good example.
The discovery of this emanation
from the Big Bang that I study
called the cosmic microwave
background radiation,
it's an all-pervasive glow
of radio or microwaves.
It was discovered
completely serendipitously
by two radio astronomers in
of all places, New Jersey,
Holmdel, New Jersey, and
they couldn't get rid of it.
But the reason that they were so vital
to even the communication
technology that we're having now,
they were working at Bell Laboratories.
Now, Bell Laboratories
doesn't exist anymore,
at least in that form, and
that's much more detrimental,
I think, a place that
was doing pure research,
studying astronomy, how
could that have any benefit?
And yet, David, who better to mind
precious weak radio signals
that would then lead
to cellphone technology
than those that study basic
pure, aka, useless science
like my fellow astronomers?
So, the point is you can never really tell
where serendipity will strike
and where that will lead to technology
that could scarcely have been imagined
even a few decades earlier.
- If I can harken back to "Contact,"
which I think I'm gonna do
20 times in this interview.
- Yeah, we should.
- There's a great debate at one moment.
It's just a few minutes
long between Ellie Arroway,
who of course is Jodie Foster,
and Tom Skerritt who plays the head
of the science foundation, are saying,
and they're arguing about public funding
versus whether the...
Could we do pure research
that has no sort of
empirical value necessarily
that we know about at that
moment, versus as he says,
"Well, the people that
are footing the bill
should get something out of this."
So that must be the endless
battle between the bureaucrat,
the scientist, and the
taxpayer, I suppose.
- Yeah, some people say
the problem with science
is that it often produces technology.
So because it produces
technology on occasion,
we expect it to always produce it.
It's like a great base runner in baseball,
he may be a good sprinter,
but that's not exactly
their core competency.
So yes, I think you have to
do serendipitous research,
and a great society like
ours should do serendipitous
or, aka, useless research.
- Chapter two is Rainer
Weiss, the Tinkerer.
- So, Rainer or Ray Weiss,
as we know and love him,
I think he's the oldest
laureate in the book,
but he's so energetic.
He was responsible in part,
along with Barry Barish,
who is a good friend of mine
and wrote the foreword to the book,
the two of them and their
colleague at Caltech, Kip Thorne,
responsible for one of
your favorite movies,
"Interstellar," I know.
- It's up there,
it's up there.
- Yep, he was a physics consultant on it.
Anyway, these three gentlemen,
along with a thousand other people,
which I wanna keep making the point
that science is not done by
the one individual per chapter.
Oftentimes it's hundreds,
even thousands in the
case of Rainer Weiss.
In this instance, they measured
the faint reverberations
of spacetime caused by sun times a 30.
So imagine a black hole 30
times the mass of the sun
colliding together, smashing apart,
and reverberating
spacetime like a drumhead.
Oh, and by the way, it's 1.3
billion light years away,
so these signals travel
for over a billion years
to get to us.
Now, he credits some of these techniques
that he used with his colleagues
to detect this most minute fluctuations
in the spacetime continuum, literally,
to his tinkering days as a
young boy in the '30s and '40s,
having just escaped
Germany with his father,
who I believe is Jewish.
He was living in New York and
he would go to flea markets
and pick up phonographs and vacuum tubes
and just tinker around with them.
And in so doing, he kept
not just the passion.
Again, I think passion is
necessary, but not sufficient.
Curiosity is the fuel that will take you
on this sustained journey.
And that's what's kept him going.
And to me, Dave, what he told me,
the advice that I take away the most,
is that if you're not having
fun, you're doing it wrong.
The dirty little secret, and
please don't tell your friend,
Gavin Newsom, this, please.
- My good buddy, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I am a state employee.
He is my boss at some level, right?
So I'm a University of California
professor, proud to be so.
I would do what I do for free, Dave.
It is so much fun.
I get to work with the brightest people,
not just in California, around the world.
I get to talk to people in my outreach,
my podcast, et cetera.
And I get to play around with technology,
paid for by you, the taxpayer,
and you pay your taxes,
I've checked into that.
And so I view it as my obligation
to give back free
information to the public.
So, I view that as my moral obligation.
It's not a business, I don't
make any money from it.
But I, like Ray Weiss,
find this great pleasure
in reinventing what I do every so often
in order to better
communicate to the customer,
which is the scientific tax-paying public.
- Brian, I suddenly
feel probably 2% happier
about my California taxes.
You moved me about 2%.
- Arizona can wait.
- Sheldon Glashow, the Nucleator.
- Shelley or Sheldon Glashow,
so he's the namesake, inspiration
for "The Big Bang Theory,"
Sheldon, "Young Sheldon."
He's a throwback, too.
He's an older guy, and
he really made his way
doing something quite unique.
My wife told me last
night, she was reading it,
and yeah, I wrote
another book before this,
I'm not convinced she
read that book, Dave,
but don't tell her I said so,
although she's a big fan of yours,
so she'll be disappointed to know
if you read that first book and not this.
Anyway, so she was
reading and she was like,
"This is so appropriate."
Because what he discovered,
like the discovery that
electricity and magnetism
in technical physics terms
are basically two different aspects
of one underlying physical law,
and that's called electromagnetism.
So that you can turn, a small
current can move a motor
and spin a motor, you
could also spin that motor
and generate a current.
That's in fact how currents
and electrical power generation works.
So he discovered the
analog of that unification
in what's called the nuclear force.
It's not super important to get into,
but it really delineated how
these things that we perceive,
very different,
a magnet that you put on your refrigerator
and a nine-volt battery,
they seem very different,
but they are different manifestations
of the same underlying coin.
He did so with his colleagues,
Steven Weinberg and Abdus
Salam, in the '60s and '70s,
they discovered a similar
feature of the nuclear force.
And my wife was reading, and she's like,
"This is so interesting,
because what one person
perceives as a manifestation,
say pure electricity,
another will perceive as magnetism,
or as one person sees as electricity
will see as a nuclear force."
That's so interesting, because
could you imagine, Dave,
as you do often and you
talk about it in your book,
can you argue the other person's side?
Can you do that?
Because otherwise, as you said,
debate is kind of pointless,
like, "Oh, Joe Biden did a
great debating with Trump.
I'm gonna vote for him
now, I was a diehard..."
No, that never happens.
But if you can say, "I
see your perspective,"
And literally it is just as kosher,
just as good as another
person's perspective,
well, then why not use that as a metaphor
for how we could be maybe
a little less polarized?
So, I like that she got it,
I wasn't intending to say
that, but it did come out
and from her interpretation
of reading this chapter
about how things that
appear so different, Dave,
are really the same manifestation
of the underlying same phenomenon.
- We actually could use a little bit more
of that in politics.
I'm sure I could use a little bit more
of it personally as well.
Then there's an interstitial.
Should we go into the interstitial?
Why'd you throw an
interstitial into the book?
Do people have to get people and pee?
What's going on here?
- I got paid by the word.
No, it's a short book.
There's no physics equations,
There's no homework.
Although you being a master
of quantum electrodynamics
would have done quite well if there were.
- Naturally.
- I had custom illustrations
and I should say I have a podcast
where I give away all these interviews.
You don't have to buy, I hope you will.
I hope you will get the
audio or the printed book.
But I actually wanted to
really make this point clear.
There is no one way to do science, Dave,
like you asked me in the
beginning about science.
There is no science says
or follow the science.
There's not even science.
Science is essentially,
basically, a shortcut, a hack,
for us unraveling fundamental
truths that never is perfect,
is guaranteed to be imperfect.
And so to some of us
it gives great comfort
because you can never
get the right answer.
In other words, Newton was darn smart
and he is responsible for the laws
that take Elon Musk, SpaceX, to the stars
and took the Apollo astronauts
to the surface of the moon.
But if you wanna go and understand
the properties of a black
hole, his work will not do
and you need Einstein.
Well, guess what?
Einstein is not the right answer either.
And we're gonna find some
subsequent improvement to it,
maybe quantum gravity, which we'll get at.
We have a 10-part learning
company series, you and I,
on that, so we can refer
people to that lecture series.
But that's not quantum.
- Yes, yes, I remember.
- And guess what?
That won't be the final answer either.
So I want to show that
there's different approaches
to arriving at truth.
You can manifest them.
I was talking to Tom
Bilyeu who lives in LA,
is a famous podcaster, great guy.
I had him on the show, I was
actually at his laboratory.
And he told me his way
that he works through,
when he was at Quest Nutrition
and he was developing these really tasty,
but nutritious bars,
protein bars, whatever,
and the scientific
method that he was using
and how he also applies
it to venture capital
or to now he's into NFTs and
Bitcoin and stuff like that.
But it's a process of thinking
guaranteed to be imperfect,
but better than all the rest.
So I want to outline how you can do it.
My avatar is a car salesman
in Tulsa, Oklahoma,
It's not a scientist.
It's not written for science majors.
And that you can apply
methodological thinking,
testing hypothesis,
listening to your critics,
achieving consensus,
and realizing in-surreptitiously perhaps,
that when you hear things
like 99% of scientists agree,
you should be very concerned.
You should be very concerned.
- We hear an awful lot
about that these days,
on many fronts, actually, not just COVID,
climate change, all sorts of things.
Carl Wieman the Teachers' Teacher.
- Yeah, so for a long time,
I had been kind of an
acolyte of Malcolm Gladwell,
who popularized, he didn't
invent this concept,
but the so-called 10,000 hour rule.
So I did a little math.
You've been doing podcasting,
"The Rubin Report,"
since the 2000s, the early 2000s.
You've had way more than 10,000 hours.
But the study that Gladwell
and Anders Ericsson popularized
was that basically the best pilots
have 10,000 hours of flight experience.
Bill Gates had like 10,000
hours of computer programming
by the time Microsoft.
Steve Jobs had 10,000, so he'd done...
Basically, it's not a scientific analysis,
it's really correlative.
And I wanted to know,
well, we as professors,
we never really get taught how to teach.
It's very rare.
You may be interested in
teaching and pedagogy,
but we have so many other obligations
in addition to teaching,
research, funding, bureaucracy,
and getting through all the
different hoops of working,
not just at a state
university, any university.
And then teaching is on there
and it's a big priority.
It's the reason we get into it.
But oftentimes we're distracted
by other quotidian demands.
And in this case, I wanted
to kind of demystify,
how should we be teaching?
Because I don't know if you know it,
but the way that we
teach with like some dude
scraping a piece of rock
on another piece of rock,
that is almost exactly a
thousand-year-old model.
It's not been disrupted
since the year 1080
in Bologna, Italy,
when the first modern university
incarnation came along,
where you'd have some guy.
But the only thing that's better now
is that back then, Dave, the
students could go on strike
and the professors would not get paid.
So, thank God we have tenure.
I mean, yeah, that is barbaric.
That is a barbaric practice.
But other than that, what has changed?
So I got into all sorts of things.
Could we have an artificial
intelligent professor?
Could we alleviate some of the burden,
but also free up the minds
and the time of the student to do it.
And he likened our current
practice of teaching
to the medical practices
of the 18 and 17th century
with leeches and bloodletting.
He said we're at a primitive state
and we need to go beyond that.
He has some models to do it.
I don't think any of them are foolproof,
but the key takeaway I took, Dave,
is that to be a good teacher,
you have to be a student of teaching.
And I pointed out in the book
that the word scientist
in the Russian language
means someone who was taught.
To me that conveys an obligation.
You both have to be a good student,
but you have to be a good teacher
to pay it forward to the next generation.
And so I think he exemplifies that to me
and really made me wanna double down
and be a better teacher
by studying teaching.
And that's not something I
really have that much time to do,
but I find a little bit of
effort goes a long way with it.
And I hope in anybody's field,
the way to learn something,
to be a better salesman,
to be a better podcaster.
I think I asked you when
you came out, I was like,
"How do you know Dave, when
you're giving a good interview,
when you're doing a good
job as an interviewer?"
You don't have a grader anymore,
but you must study it and
you must listen to it,
and even if that means
studying with people
that maybe you don't
agree with all the time,
you can learn a lot.
And that's part of the humble nature
that I think it takes to be a good student
and, ergo, a good teacher.
- It's interesting because
as you're talking about that,
I'm thinking of all of the videos
that we see on Twitter everyday,
where a student will
take a video of a teacher
just doing everything wrong,
either the way they're
trying to brainwash them
or yell at them and whatever.
And it's just like, man,
there is so much broken in our
education system altogether,
but that's for a different show.
Roger Penrose, the Singular Mind.
- Ah, yes, so Roger just
celebrated his 90th birthday
and he made appearance in
"The Theory of Everything,"
the movie with Eddie Redmayne, I guess,
and that was about Stephen Hawking,
who is his famous late, great friend
and collaborator and
colleague at Cambridge
while Roger was at Oxford.
So, Roger came up with really whimsical,
almost whimsical drawings
and cartoons and schematics
that demonstrate what would
happen to your watch, Dave,
as you get close to a black hole.
What would happen as you go beyond
what's called the event horizon,
how would things proceed?
How would your future look?
How would you look to
someone on the outside world?
And he did this very intuitively
through a series of cartoons almost.
And it's in his tradition as an artist,
he's really a mathematician,
and he's invented these wonderful things
that are evocative of Escher,
drawings with staircases that
just seem to keep going up
or these fishes that tile this
whole sphere and so forth.
And he thinks geometrically,
he thinks artistically.
His dad was an artist.
And many of these men, unfortunately,
I tried to get the two
living Nobel Prize laureates
in physics that are female.
They both rejected me, so that
took me back to high school,
and getting rejected by brilliant women.
(Dave laughing)
But for various reasons,
they weren't able to do it.
- Interesting.
- But I'm hoping hope springs
eternal and I'll keep going.
I hope there's more female
laureates, obviously.
I have daughters myself
and then maybe someday
they could be among them.
But the point being, when I asked them,
the most common thing I got
was a father or a teacher.
And I took that very seriously.
Again, that you can be a father,
even if you don't have
biological children.
These men are ideological
fathers in some sense
to millions of people around the world.
And yet they haven't
written their biography.
I mean, none of them have a biography,
which is kind of interesting.
So I wanted to do that as a service
such that maybe someone
could be influenced by them
the way that they've influenced me
through their technical writing.
But you might not know that
actually they're really good
with dealing with vengeful
competitors and things like that.
That is actually what we deal
with day-to-day, isn't it?
It's not stroking my non-existent beard,
thinking about contemplating the cosmos.
I get to do that on
occasion, but not that often.
Mostly it's dealing with
troublesome suppliers and vendors
and getting equipment to the site
and the student's having a problem.
I wanted to go beyond that.
And I think having mentors
and avuncular figures
like I do in the book,
I think, I'm hoping that
that will influence people
to see the human side of science.
- Right, and also of course,
doing some of this
through art and technology
can awaken people in a way
that just the guy at
the chalkboard can't do.
How did "Interstellar" do in that regard
when they were going over
that event horizon, right?
Because they had to drop the robot.
I forget what he was called,
TARS had to be dropped in.
There's a lot of imagery there
about light can't escape
from the other side
and all of that stuff.
How'd they do, how'd they do?
- So that was all influenced
by Sir Roger Penrose
who influenced Kip Thorne,
who is another laureate that
I hope to get on the show
who was responsible for
winning the Nobel Prize,
along with colleagues,
for the LIGO experiment,
Ray Weiss we already talked about.
You can take a lot of what
I call physicist license
because these things are not approachable.
It's not like...
I was talking on a
podcast earlier this week
with a biology professor
and she was talking about,
and I was like, "Don't
talk to me about that
because I'm so bad at biology
that when I dissected
a frog in high school,
the frog lived."
I just couldn't do it.
But in astronomy, so in other words,
you can't do an experiment.
I can't say, "Hmm,
Dave, what if the cosmos
had twice as much dark matter?
Oh, let me just, I'm God,"
and no, no, you can't do that.
Whereas you can have a
control and a variable
and do stuff in biology.
So astronomy and in particular
cosmology is very hard.
But what you can do is take
a lot of artistic license.
The fact that you can't
go near a black hole,
you can't go back to the Big Bang,
means that you can do
a lot with simulations
that really let the imagination run wild.
- I think that was your way of saying
that the "Interstellar"
scene was pretty cool
as he was going through things.
- It was.
What happened, I never saw it.
I had to go to the Mexican border
to get like a global entry
card a few years back.
I hadn't seen "Interstellar,"
and the guy in front of
me was a professor also
at Scripps Institution of Oceanography.
And I was like, "Oh,
crap, they're gonna think
like it's a conspiracy.
All these professors
are coming to the border
to get their passport or
to get their whatever."
And the guy said to me,
first, I heard him ask the guy
in front of me some questions,
then he said to me like,
"Um, well, oh, you're an astrophysicist.
You think you're smarter than me?
You got a pretty big gun over there.
I better be careful."
And I said, well, I hadn't seen it, Dave,
so I had to think fast
on my feet, and I said,
"Well, um, Interstellar, hmm."
He asked me, "What do you
think about 'Interstellar?'
You're so smart."
"Well, the gravitational
spacetime continuum can be warped
by four dimensions, but
not in a manifestation."
And I just BS'd my way out of it.
But luckily, I only spent three nights
in the Tijuana prison.
- I've been doing that my
whole life with "Star Wars,"
so you're good to go.
Duncan Haldane, the Alchemist.
- Yeah, so this is a guy
who along with colleagues
invented a theoretical type of matter,
a phase of matter not known to exist
and purely intellectually.
It's so weird, Dave, it's actually...
We exist in three dimensions.
We can go up, down, backwards,
forwards, left, right.
But he envisioned a two-dimensional world,
very different with time proceeding,
but also confined to two dimensions.
Like an ant would feel
bulbous and curvy, right?
But a flat surface.
And then he asked,
"Well, what would matter
behave like then?"
And he speculated,
and he came up with
this new type of matter
and it would have certain properties
and would behave in an interesting way.
But everyone thought it
was purely mathematical,
until experimental physicists devised ways
to actually simulate a
two-dimensional world
by basically printing
with very special media types of exotic...
And then they found that these
objects behaved differently
in two dimensions than three dimensions.
So he really conceived in
his mind of a new element,
of a new type of matter, and
I found that very interesting.
And so I call him the Alchemist, yeah,
so he was very clever.
Alchemists, of course, were people
that thought they could turn
ordinary base metals into gold,
and actually some of the
greatest minds in history
like Isaac Newton did that.
And that's actually part of what you said
in the very beginning, because
actually the hard sciences,
they have pretty shaky past histories.
Chemistry evolved
essentially from alchemy.
Astronomy evolved from astrology.
And obviously, medicine
evolved from leeches
and bloodletting like
we talked about earlier.
I think we have a tendency
to want to kind of glorify,
oh, the scientific method.
And there is no scientific
method, that's full stop.
There are ways to methodologically
approach scientific
or knowledge-based questions.
And I think this way of coming
up with a new form of matter
purely in the human brain,
I think that's just so fascinating.
- How long did it take
before he met the guy
that was able to actually
replicate it in the real world?
- Years, years, and it's funny
because in the interview at the end,
he starts talking about,
"Well, I don't think this
is gonna make a new iPhone.
It's not gonna improve your life."
But I was like, the history
of science tells us otherwise,
like there's a very good chance.
If you ask these guys who discovered
this hiss of microwaves back in the '60s,
would we be able to watch?
I always say my grandmother, Dave,
she grew up in the (indistinct)
seeing horse and buggies,
and she grew up to see human beings, men,
walking on the surface of TikTok.
(Dave laughing)
And how wonderful is that?
So I'm like telling this guy, Haldane,
"Don't underestimate what
the human mind can do
with enough time."
- Frank Wilczek a beautiful mind.
- Yeah, Frank Wilczek, he
is a professor at MIT now.
And when he was in his early 20s, Dave,
he came up with an idea so brilliant
along with his colleagues,
that it was guaranteed
to win a Nobel Prize.
In 1974, he was told he is
the wunderkind of science.
He is going to guarantee to
make a trip to Stockholm.
There's just one catch,
there's about 20 other
guys in front of you
that have to get their Nobel Prizes almost
in order for you to have the
validation and the verification
that is necessary in the scientific method
to get consensus around this physics idea.
Now, Dave, I imagine, if I told you.
"You're gonna win the lottery
next week, next year,"
you'd be pretty happy.
If I told you we're
gonna win it in 30 years,
what would go through your mind?
I think that I'd be thinking about,
"Hm, I gotta stay alive.
I gotta cut back on the burgers."
But imagine that terror and the pressure,
and so many of them, I think,
there was such a long delay
between the work that won
them the prize eventually,
and the actual awarding of the prize
on December 10th every
year in Stockholm, Sweden,
and I think that that is a lesson
in resiliency and perseverance
because he also didn't rest on that.
I might just say, "Okay, cool.
Put me in a coma, put on the feeding tube,
this Woody Allen in "Sleeper" outfit,
and wake me up when Stockholm.
But no, he didn't.
He went on to invent or
create many, many new things.
And he's an inspiration
in many ways from that.
He's also a great writer.
He writes for "The Wall Street Journal,"
a science column for "The
Wall Street Journal,"
which is, you know, it's
not technical at all.
He's an incredible intellect.
- Speaking of Woody Allen and "Sleeper,"
do we still not have
the cryo sleep things?
I mean, they were in "Interstellar," too.
They're in all the alien movies.
Do those things exist?
Where are we at with those things?
- I don't know.
Every time I go down to
my biology lab colleagues,
they're always asleep or dissecting frogs.
If you had access to those
many chemicals and drugs, Dave,
what would you be doing, come on?
- You would put yourself in a
bag in some hot water usually,
and then they get you.
It was in "The Martian," too,
with what's his name.
- You gonna put them
in one of those brownies
that you still have leftover from 1997.
- Exactly, I wish had those.
John Mather, the Collaborator.
- Yeah, John is an incredible guy
who also is kind of a wunderkind
and did a tremendous amount of work.
He is the stereotypical,
although he's not a professor,
he's a stereotypical
professor, just super smart,
can answer and knows
everything about the field
and has contributed to many,
many great discoveries,
and is about to be the chief scientist
behind this new space telescope
that's gonna be launched
in December, hopefully,
after a 20-year delay.
It's one of the most expensive
projects NASA's ever done.
And it's a successor to
the Hubble Space Telescope,
which has revealed more wonders
and mysteries of the cosmos
than any other project.
And so he discovered not serendipitously,
so he's an example of a different type
of scientific discovery,
which is that you make an
extremely precise measurement
of a known quantity, something
that we knew existed,
this microwave background
radiation that I study.
Comes in all directions,
originally discovered in New Jersey.
But he made the most
exquisite measurement ever
that put the nail in the coffin
of any other alternatives
that could plausibly be
said to be responsible
for the appearance of our universe.
Namely, there are people
that believed up until then
in the early '90s,
that the universe could
have existed forever.
in what's called the steady-state.
And the measurements that
he did for technical reasons
really destroyed all hope
for those who believed in an alternative
to what we now call the Big
Bang initiation of the universe.
So he is this really
quintessential workman-like,
studious, bookish, very, very
bright, very, very diligent.
He just keeps going.
Again, these guys could all
retire and be super famous
and do whatever they wanna do.
And yet he's working super hard
on this next great space telescope,
the dividends of which may
not come for decades or more.
- How does it go for a guy like that
when he sort of puts that
final nail as you put it
and it sort of blows up
what many in his field
think about something?
I suspect there's probably
a lot of resentment.
There's probably a lot of denial.
But slowly kind of people
come along usually?
- Yeah, well, that's what's so
interesting in that chapter.
He talks about the importance
of listening to your critics,
but not too much.
And I kinda summarize this
as a trait in my students.
I say you have to be humble.
Nobody likes someone who's not humble.
And we'll talk about
imposter syndrome and stuff
in a little bit, I'm sure.
But you need humility,
but you need swagger, too.
You need the swagger to know
that you're doing a good job,
that you are competent.
You can't just go, "Oh,
I'm timid, I'm humble,
I can't do anything."
And in his case, there were
these really vociferous calls
that the Big Bang is wrong
and it's actually just a product
of the religious scientist,
if you can believe such a thing,
and this impulse that human beings have
to believe in Genesis
1:1, et cetera, et cetera.
And in the end, he said, "You
can listen to those people.
You can respect their
scientific contributions.
But you shouldn't listen so much
that you really undermine
your own confidence."
So it's listening to your critics,
not necessarily letting their
comments go to your heart,
but maybe ingesting them into your mind,
processing them analytically,
and saying, "Is there a way?"
And I translated this and
we talked about this before.
Can you steelman your critic?
And can you build up his
or her counterargument
to your pet theory or pet experiment?
And if you can't, it's not a
guarantee that you're wrong.
You may be right and they may
be just a blundering idiot
who just believes in some stupid model.
But in the case where you can actually
reproduce their arguments,
it makes your case that much more strong.
And I think that's a trait I
want to imbue in other people
to take to heart no
matter what their field,
and I think he exemplifies that.
- I suspect that goes far
better in the laboratories
that you people work in
rather than the Twitterscape.
I'm pretty sure I don't need
to run an experiment on that.
My life has been a living
experiment of that.
We've got one more, and
then if you don't mind,
I'm going to throw in my own scientist.
I have not planned anything
in advance with you,
but I'm gonna throw in someone
that has influenced me tremendously.
- Absolutely.
- But the last one, number nine,
Barry Barish, the Avuncular Avatar.
- Yeah, so Barry kind of
represents the physicist
that I wanna be and in
the avatar aspect of that.
And avuncular 'cause
he is just such a warm,
gracious individual.
So Barry really in some
ways is responsible
for this book's existence
because it was during the
recording of this episode
with him on my podcast,
"Into the "Impossible,"
that he said something that
was kind of interesting
and provocative to me.
And then I went further,
learning the Rubinic skills
that I've learned from
you, and I went deeper.
What are you talking about?
He said to me, Dave, and it blew me away,
I said, "When you were young,
were you like this stereotypical
brilliant kid in math?"
And he's like, "No, I
was never, I was good,
I was a hard worker, I was smart."
But he grew up in Oklahoma
and then later moved to LA and so forth.
And then he was just like persistent
and he always wanted to
do a certain type of work
called particle physics.
But he was never under this
impression that he was great.
And I said, "Did you ever
have the imposter syndrome
when you were at UC Berkeley
working for these famous
Nobel laureate physicists?
Did you ever feel like
you weren't good enough?"
He goes, "What do you mean, did I?
I still feel the imposter syndrome."
I was like, "What are you talking about?"
He said, "I feel it worse than ever."
And I said, "You gotta explain,
what are you talking about?"
And he said, "When you
win the Nobel prize,
you go to Stockholm, you
meet the king, you bend down,
and he puts this golden
Gildan engraved image
of Alfred Nobel on your neck,
and you get a check for some fraction
or 100% of a million dollar payout,
and you get this portrait,
this really beautiful portrait.
I tried to reproduce the portrait
with a really nice work
of an artist in this book.
I think he did a wonderful job.
And then you have to sign
this ledger that says,
"Yes, I received my Nobel Prize
and all the accoutrements
and delicacies therein."
And he said, "When I did that,
I'm a very curious person,
I couldn't resist who
signed it before me."
So he turned back the pages.
He saw Richard Feynman. Marie Curie,
and he saw Albert Einstein.
And he said, Dave, and
the hair still stands up,
and he said, "I'm not worthy.
I am not Einstein.
I am not good enough to be there.
And it made me feel completely inadequate,
completely not up to the task.
And now I'm in the same
league as Einstein.
I do not deserve it."
And I said, thinking quickly,
I said, "Barry, guess what?
You know who also had
the imposter syndrome?
Albert Einstein.
Because Albert Einstein was in awe
and wholly inadequate
before Isaac Newton."
And he felt Isaac Newton, Dave,
can you imagine if Einstein
were tweeting today?
He said the following.
He said, "Isaac Newton
revolutionized not only science,
but Western culture,
Western civilization."
He'd get canceled immediately.
He said, "Newton had more
influence on civilization,
not just science, than any
human before or since,"
meaning including Albert Einstein
who was writing this about Newton.
And I said, "But wait,
Barry, it doesn't stop there.
Isaac Newton had the severe
case of the imposter syndrome."
He said, "What do you mean?"
I said, "He felt completely
inadequate before his idol,
not a scientist, but Jesus Christ."
In fact, Newton said his
highest accomplishment in life
is that he died a virgin,
like Jesus Christ,
and he wanted to emulate
Christ in every way.
So, I think it's very fascinating.
And guess what?
I don't know, (laughing)
maybe Jesus didn't feel
the imposter syndrome,
but he was pretty humble
and I think he was a pretty
brilliant human being,
or God, depending on
your perspective, right?
So, I think we all can learn this lesson
because if you think that
you're the greatest person
and you have these great contributions
and you have like, "I
won the Nobel prize,"
like there are guys,
I'm not gonna say who,
but there are people in the book who said,
"I don't have the imposter syndrome,
I deserve this fricking thing,"
like Flavor Flav with the huge
medallion around his neck.
But they feel like they deserve
it, but not all of them.
And I think that it was a dichotomy
that I wasn't suspecting.
It was a dichotomy that you need to have,
like I said, humility and swagger,
but you need to be very careful about it
because the imposter syndrome
is born out of insecurity,
and people that are
arrogant and unpleasant,
they're also insecure, right?
- Mm-mm.
The old joke, and you
know this from your dog,
the smallest dog barks the loudest, right?
That's the thing, right?
You talked to Jocko on your podcast.
Jocko's not like, ""Oh,
I'm gonna kick your..."
He's just like, "Whatever,
man, I'll run away.
I'll put on my running
shoes and get out of there."
So, I think that's really interesting
'cause it's very rare that the opposite,
two different traits
in diametric opposition
come from the same source.
Insecurity is responsible
for imposter syndrome
and for the arrogance that
many non-humble people feel.
So, I felt it was
important to distill this,
and who better to learn it from
than someone who's achieved
and gotten into the
promised land of my field
is the Nobel Prize.
There's no higher thing in all of science,
maybe even all of culture,
civilization, and society
than the Nobel Prize.
And so I felt these people,
and in particular Barry,
and I was so honored
that he wrote the foreword
to the book as well.
That was really a great honor
that I do not feel worthy of.
- Brian, that was a beautiful ending
to the interview in a normal situation.
But I feel that I must ask
you about one other scientist
who was hugely influential
I believe at Queens College,
and I think maybe he
was a nuclear scientist,
Dr. Otto Octavius.
Do you know of him?
- (laughing) Octavius, no, I
do not know of him personally.
Is he a Nobel caliber scientist?
- Doc Ock from "Spider-Man."
Doc Ock.
- Octopus.
- He was doing something with
nuclear power with the arms,
and then he got them fused to his back,
and then the little
inhibitor chip blew up.
Next thing you know, he's
working with Mysterio
and the rest of the guys.
- Spider-Man was very prescient
because he also pre-staged the
existence of the multiverse
and the Spider-Verse, right?
- And now we're all
entering the multiverse,
that's the new thing.
There's this rumor going around now
that Facebook's actually
gonna rename itself
the multiverse or something?
Have you heard about this?
- (laughing) No, I have
not heard about that.
Yeah, no, that makes me
want to take a sabbath
from all social media networks,
except to subscribe to your feed.
- I've thoroughly enjoyed this.
Actually, I have one more for you,
which is, are we living in a simulation?
- Ah, this is a fascinating-
- How's that for a final question?
- Well, usually, Dave,
people have preface it,
"I have a simple question,
like how do you reconcile believing in God
with the existence of the Big Bang?"
And there, that would be a
simple question, the simulation.
So what's so interesting
about the simulation
is that it actually has a lot of bases
in both classical philosophy,
kind of the Pascal's wager,
kind of the Descartean, cogito, ergo sum,
I think therefore I am.
People don't realize
that that was predicated.
So Descartes said, "How do I know
I'm not just a brain in a vat?"
Basically, that was their
simulation of the time.
And he said, "I know I am not
because I think, therefore I am."
But there was a predicate sentence,
which was that God created him.
So in other words, actually,
Descartes can't answer
that question without God.
And it's funny because
the simulation hypothesis,
for the listeners that may not know,
is basically the supposition
that as computing power doubles
every year, year and a half,
according to what's known as Moore's law,
your computers get cheaper,
they get more powerful,
they get faster, and
that that extrapolation,
there's no natural starting point,
I mean, when you made the
first computer or whatever
that for us is.
But could it not be that
they get to so much power,
that they can simulate
every single physical object
in the universe and they can simulate,
and if we're just material objects,
our brains are just wet computers,
but they're just computers,
they have neurons, they have
carbon, and DNA and so forth,
but why couldn't that be simulated
in some great, vast
supercomputer of the future
that doesn't exist yet?
But we would be kind of like
the "SimCity" or whatever.
- Right, we'd be in
"The Matrix" in essence.
- Yeah, we'd be in "The Matrix."
So, there are a lot of ways
to actually test for that
and actually probe for it.
There's no evidence that
we are in a simulation,
that we do live in a matrix.
For one question, it could
have this infinite regress
of possibilities.
So you could say to me,
"We are in a simulation."
I could say, "Well, whoever
made that simulation,
they're a simulation,
and whoever made that simulation..."
And so you would have to have an infinite,
not just a large amount of computer,
you need an infinite
amount of computing power,
and there would be certain glitches.
The first thing I would want to know is,
why are there so many damn Kardashians?
Why do we need so many
Kardashians in this simulation?
But I think it stems from
both extrapolating the computing power,
which actually isn't growing,
in terms of like the number of
transistors, that's growing,
but because the computers
get better and better,
more people wanna use them, Dave,
and actually they start to slow down
because their demands are so much higher.
They're victims of their own success.
And there's no reason to
think that won't happen
either with quantum computers or whatever.
And the last thing I wanna say is that,
imagine if there is a simulation
and there is some simulator,
and let's say it's not
infinite, there's just one,
what ethical responsibilities
does that simulation have
to the things that it's simulating?
'Cause we feel pain.
You could imagine we can create
artificial intelligence, AI,
and that could feel pain.
You could make it
so that if it does
something you don't like,
you unplug it, or you pop a transistor,
or you nail a capacitor in the
middle of the circuit board
and it could feel pain.
But can it feel the kinds of inspiration,
the ghost in the machine?
We don't know yet if that's possible.
I happen to be a pessimist.
I don't think that artificial intelligence
will take over the universe
or even create new physics or
new art or things like that.
That's categorically different
from what we're seeing now.
In other words, I like to say,
humans can be beaten
by computers at chess,
but can a computer invent a game of chess?
I don't think so.
- Brian, you are an excellent
science communicator.
I've thoroughly enjoyed this.
It was a little different
from our day-to-day political lunacy,
but I suspect my audience
will enjoy it as well.
We are gonna link to the
book right down below,
and I've enjoyed this.
But for the record, not
a huge fan of your boss,
Gavin Newsom, just in
case anyone was unclear
on their feelings on that.
- Well, we'll see if you
get tenure after that.
- Thanks, Brian.
- I'll put in a good word, but we'll see.
- If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about academia
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our academia playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist.
They're all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.